[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese comedy drama
film called you are not alone spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
z-way is a 27-year-old man who has never
been in a relationship he practically
lives at work because coming home to a
girlfriend-less house is dreadful
moreover he has no family relatives or
friends which makes his life terribly
boring on the morning before his 28th
birthday zeeway's boss calls him to the
office and fires him his reason is that
z-way's sad life makes the other
employees sad and decreases their
productivity zeeway begs him to
reconsider since he shouldn't be sad on
his birthday but the boss says being
unemployed at 27 is better than being
unemployed at 28. in the evening zeeway
goes to a bar to drink on either side of
him are couples enjoying their time
together while z-way complains about his
life to a bartender suddenly a group of
robbers barge in and hold everyone at
gunpoint they order the people to call
their close ones and ask for ransom only
when the other person delivers the money
will they be let free everyone
immediately calls their parents friends
partners or spouse but z-way is stuck an
hour later the last person pays the
money and leaves but z-way is still on
the ground even the robbers feel bad for
him and lent him an ear so he can talk
about his problems the robbery somehow
turns into a therapy session as they
help z-way with his emotions they even
contemplate giving him some of the money
they collected but then the police
arrive outside the robbers bring z-way
outside at gunpoint to find out that he
was the one who called the police they
realized they should never have trusted
someone as lonely as z-way but it is too
late in the following shootout all of
them are killed zeeway tries to walk to
the policemen when he slips on a banana
peel and ends up in the hospital his
loneliness becomes a drawback once again
when the doctor asks his guardian to
sign a consent form when he has no
guardian but then a miracle happens and
a pretty girl comes forward as his
girlfriend and signs the papers z-way
recovers in no time after being treated
and returns home without thanking the
girl he sets up a birthday cake for
himself like he has been doing since his
parents death 10 years ago suddenly he
hears a knock on the door and opens it
to find the girl from the hospital on
the other side unused to talking with
women z-way closes the door on her face
the girl forcefully pushes it open and
introduces herself as an insurance agent
named angel it turns out that before
their death zeeway's parents signed him
up for a program where if he is unable
to find a girlfriend by the time he's 28
the insurance company will provide him
with one they knew their son had no game
ever since he was eight years old angel
shows him a magical ring that is
supposed to turn an object into a girl
that way z-way can choose any item in
his room and turn it into his girlfriend
she will already know everything about
z-way so he won't have to do much to
impress her he can even use the ring for
a trial and confirm his purchase only
when he finds a girlfriend of his choice
in the evening z-way is in his bathroom
when he accidentally drops the soap it
immediately turns into a girl named
soapy who is obsessed with cleaning she
tries to help him bathe but zeeway is
too shy to let her he pushes her out the
door and soapy comes across a trashed
room a while later zeeway comes out of
the bathroom to see his place is the
cleanest it has ever been at night they
sleep together but soapy accidentally
pushes him off the bed she follows him
everywhere he goes obsessively cleaning
everything he touches z-way meets angel
and complains that he would prefer a
thinner girlfriend angel judges him
because of the comment but reveals that
he should use all of soapy to get rid of
her starting that day z-way showers
every hour when soapy begins to complain
that he is not dirty he goes to play
football with the neighborhood kids
although he rolls on the ground more
than he plays it does the job after the
match soapy is so eager to clean him
that she insists on going to the public
shower room where all the other players
are also present while she lathers z-way
with soap the others think they're doing
something else z-way comes out a while
later and a guy makes fun of him for
having an overweight girlfriend suddenly
soapy comes out of the shower looking
entirely different than she did a few
minutes ago she has lost weight because
of the frequent showers z-way finally
starts liking her as a girlfriend and
doesn't want her to disappear anymore to
keep her longer he stops showering
altogether a week later he meets angel
again and tells her about his problem
with time soapy has become frustrated to
clean him but he doesn't allow it even
though he stinks at night he returns
home late hoping that she is already
asleep but soapy catches him with a
bunch of new soaps and body wash she
accuses him of cheating and runs away
outside it is raining which causes her
to disappear into bubbles a heartbroken
z-way goes to angel again she makes him
understand that he can now choose an
object that he has a connection with
rather than soap with renewed motivation
zeeway returns home and chooses his
goldfish as his next girlfriend it turns
into a beautiful japanese girl who
doesn't understand mandarin she also has
the memory of a goldfish which means she
cannot remember things for more than
seven seconds because of this she often
tries eating sushi from the fridge and
forgets who ziwei is to solve the
problem he writes his name and relation
on the girl's wrist so she would always
remember him this helps them communicate
for a few days but one morning she
accidentally wipes it off and runs away
from the house z-way sets out to look
for her and finds her eating in front of
a stall a crowd has gathered around to
watch her eat several plates of street
food when zeeway tries bringing her back
home they stop him in turn he attacks
the people who retaliate unlike his
normal self then he films a video of
them together talking about their
relationship he also starts to vlog
their daily life so she can watch it
later and remember the things they did
together but as days pass z-way becomes
tired of being the girl's mother rather
than her boyfriend one night he draws a
heart on her wrist and turns her back
into a goldfish he meets angel again the
following day and tells her that he
wants an edgy girl rather than a soft
one the perfect object for that would be
a knife hence he throws his knife to the
ground which turns it into a girl she is
just what he wanted and the complete
opposite of the goldfish girl right
after coming to life she says that she
wants to go out because the indoors are
stuffy they go on a walk but are stopped
by a group of thugs the knife is quick
to fight them and chase them away with
her sharp moves z-way is a little
intimidated so he agrees to whatever she
says she makes him drive her to a
neighboring town which is her birthplace
it turns out she is emotionally attached
to her manufacturer who used to own a
knife shop but now sells fish she sees
him using another knife and gets jealous
when he calls it the best one he has
ever used a heartbroken knife explains
to z way that she can never love him as
much as she loves her manufacturer in
the end he transforms her back into her
older version and leaves her near the
fish shop a while later the owner
notices her outside and takes her back
home at night z-way meets angel again
she is frustrated that he doesn't like
any of the girls which is blocking her
from getting her commission she thinks
he is too picky for someone who is so
desperate to get a girlfriend z-way in
turn reveals that it is difficult for
him to talk to girls because of
something that happened years ago a girl
who he thought was his girlfriend
accused him of harassment for touching
her hand on reaching home z-way throws
random objects to the ground and creates
several girls to test if they are
compatible however the cactus plant
hurts him the coffee bean is too
energetic and the russian doll creates
more girls than he wants in the end he
decides to turn his phone into his
girlfriend since the phone knows
everything about z-way he believes his
next girlfriend will be the one it
transforms into a sophisticated woman
who can read z-way's mind without him
saying anything right after coming to
life she orders him food from his
favorite place and sets the table just
how he likes it she can help him with
anything in life because she is also the
smartest object in the room that
afternoon they go to a restaurant to
have lunch while they are at it zeeway's
former girlfriend who broke his heart
also arrives and sits at another table
she brags about her rich boyfriend to
z-way which the phone doesn't like so
she hacks into the girl's phone and
texts all of her current boyfriends they
arrive at the restaurant in no time and
her secret is revealed in front of
everyone the gesture makes z-wave fall
in love with the phone when they return
home she makes him sit by her side and
plants a kiss on his lips a while later
he falls asleep and it is revealed that
the phone is an evil object she has come
to life to make z-wave's life a living
hell for always abusing her he played
with her until her battery ran out kept
her in the toilet for hours always
dropped her around and abused her
thoroughly all this is because she
didn't have the power to say no she
wants to make him feel the same pain
that she and the other electronic
devices face on a daily basis hence she
steals his ring and converts a speaker a
magazine a robot vacuum and a first aid
box into people they join hands to
perform a surgery on z-way and turn him
into a device that will follow the
phone's orders when he wakes up he can
hardly move the first aid box confirms
that they have attached a device to
z-way's heart which means his body no
longer belongs to him meanwhile angel is
stressed because z-way doesn't like any
girls he gets she texts him to ask if he
has made any progress and gets a reply
saying that he wants to confirm the
phone as his permanent girlfriend
alongside the message a picture of him
in the phone is attached with a filter
over it angel knows that z-way hates
putting animal filters over his pictures
which makes her believe something is
wrong at home the phone makes z-way work
on her command as he did with her for so
many years when it gets dark she brings
him to a huge storage unit to find more
objects that can be turned into useful
humans she wants to create an army of
things to take over the world when z-way
is left alone angel pulls him aside
having found the truth and followed them
to the place she tries to run away with
him but is caught by the phone under her
influence z-way attacks angel and goes
against the very person helping him in
the ensuing chase angel and z-way end up
near a railing and are cornered by the
phone z-way strangles angel leaving her
no option but to push him off the
railing this causes z-wave's heart to go
back to normal it turns out that angel
also turns 28 today and is wearing the
same ring since she pushed z-way he
turned into a human from an object as it
happened with the phone the soap and the
goldfish now that he is no longer under
the phone's control she loses her mind
she sends a dumbbell to hurt them but
angel creates a man out of a barbell to
defend against the attack in the
following fight between the two objects
the barbell wins then the phone uses a
japanese katana which defeats the
barbell in no time in retaliation angel
transforms a dao sword into a warrior
who attacks the katana they get into an
intense battle at the end of which both
weapons vanish by now the phone is in
low power mode z-way notices it charging
through a cord and unplugs it turning
the phone into an actual phone and
winning the fight in the last scene
z-way and angel are on the terrace
watching over the city they take off
their rings deciding they are too
dangerous to be practical z-way asks
angel to be his girlfriend and the movie
ends as they hold hands subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching